nous reprenons maintenant les problèmes
internationaux à bonn capitale de
l'allemagne fédérale a été paraphé cet
après-midi le traité dit fondamental
c'est à dire le texte qui règle les
relations futures entre l'allemagne de
l'ouest et l'allemagne de l'est
la cérémonie a eu lieu dans la salle des
gobelins à la chancellerie fédérale
à bonn et j'appelle à bonn notre
correspondant permanent
gérard saint paul agon après les traités
de moscou et de varsovie signé en 1970
nous assistons ici au troisième acte
important de la politique à l'est de
bonnes le para cet après-midi à la
chancellerie du premier traité
fondamental entre les deux allemagnes
traité qui sera effectivement signé
après les élections du 19 novembre par
les chefs de gouvernement
les deux artisans du traité le
secrétaire d'état à la chancellerie
monsieur hengbart et son collègue est
allemand helmut kohl ont négocié
durement pendant près de deux ans ils
ont conclu un chapitre capital de
l'histoire allemande de l'après guerre
un chapitre comportant matériellement un
préambule 10 articles et toute une série
de lettres en annexe
c'est à bernard est cependant que
l'accord est intervenu dans la soirée de
lundi
voici le moment que l'on qualifie ici
d'historique
les échanges de documents entre les deux
secrétaires d'état
il aura fallu de longs efforts à
messieurs barre et coll
le secrétaire d'état ouest allemand et
son collègue est-allemand pour parvenir
à la conclusion de cet accord
fondamental la république fédérale
d'allemagne et la république
démocratique allemande ont donc décidé
de vivre un peu plus normalement en
établissant ce traité fondamental qui
réglemente leurs rapports sans pour
autant établir de relations
diplomatiques proprement dit
la voie est ainsi ouverte désormais à
l'entrée simultanée de ces deux
allemagnes à l'organisation des nations
unies l'après guerre est donc un peu
moins l'après guerre aujourd'hui c'est
une victoire également la veille des
élections pour le chancelier vibrante
car c'était une étape importante sinon
capitale pour l'ensemble de sa politique
à l'est par contre pour l'opposition au
chrétienne démocrate c'est une défaite
c'est la consécration de la division de
l'allemagne
kreiner barcel en particulier le leader
chrétien démocrates reprochent au
chancelier brand d'avoir conclu ce
traité sans parlement sans majorité est
pratiquement à la sauvette à la veille
des élections alors que cet accord dit
il engage définitivement peut-être
l'avenir de l'allemagne
mais de part et d'autre de la frontière
les allemands de bonne volonté ont jugé
qu'il était temps de vivre en bon
voisinage
même avec des systèmes socio économiques
différents voici des images de berlin
est où se trouvait ce matin encore
équipe de 24 heures sur la une
conséquence pratique de cet accord les
échanges commerciaux seront intensifiés
entre les deux républiques des chargés
de missions seront nommés à bonn et à
berlin-est des journalistes ouest
allemands pourront être accréditée en
rda des enfants séparés de leurs parents
pourront partir en allemagne de l'ouest
2000 prisonniers politiques seront
libérés et enfin 6 millions de
frontaliers occidentaux pourront se
rendre en rda neuf jours par an selon
villy brent cet accord place le peuple
allemand devant un nouveau commencement
le fossé entre les deux allemagnes dit
il c'est sera désormais de s'élargir